Please shred some information about UDU
TV channel whether it's available in
kqatar or not.
The question posed by the brother is
that he has been watching peace TV udu
since a long time but since 3 years he's
not getting the udu Islamic channel. The
name of the channel is peace TV udu. So
he's asking that is the channel running?
How can he see it? Alhamdulillah we have
got four satellite channels which are 24
by7.
Number one is peace TV English. Number
two is peace TV. Number three is peace
TV Bangla and number four is peace TV
channel Chinese.
As far as
our satellite channels are concerned we
see to it that we are present on
multiple satellites. The more number of
satellites you're present the more
number of eyeballs the more number of
people are watching. The first channel
peace TV was launched in 2006. Then we
launched peace TV uru in 200
9. Then we launched peace TV Bangla in
2011 and we launched peace TV in 2015.
As far as peace TV is concerned, peace
TV udu started in 2009 and since its
inception it's growing. It's always
there. So you are not able to watch
peace TV in Qatar. Maybe your dish has
got shifted or the duration of your dish
has shifted. As far as katar is
concerned, there are two satellites
which show peace TV group. One is the
Arab fat. The other is the interat 20.
The Arab sat is watched more by the
Arabs in Arabic as a language. The
non-Arabs they watch other satellites
and the other famous satellite is the
Indrasa 20. So alhamdulillah we are
present on both on Arab sat which is
very famous among the Arab world. It
covers the whole of the Middle East. It
covers the whole of Europe and very
beneficial. But peace TV is also seen on
intera 20 which is seen more by the
Asian people, the Indian, the Pakistani.
Intera 20. It is the satellite which has
the largest footprint. It covers more
than 70% of the world population. It is
seen in Middle East. It's seen in India.
It's seen in the Indian subcontinent.
all the countries that is Pakistan, Sri
Lanka, Bangladesh,
Maldiv etc. So peace to Udu is present
since 2009 and India is present. Only
thing you have to shift your dish. So if
you shift your dish in the angle of 68°
east then inshallah you will be able to
watch and see peace TV udu and recently
or maybe four years back we are even
telecasting of peace TV udu and peace TV
English on patat on Pakistan set. So the
business came the setup and they went
away but now it's also available on
Paxat. Thus the viewership opt increased
but previously people only used to watch
on the other platforms. So the more
number of satellites that you are in a
particular region the more number of
eyeballs because Arab sat is mainly
watched by the Arabs. didn't watch Asia
side or interrat.
So that is the reason we started even
pack so that more of the audio audience
can watch. So now at present we are on
three satellites and all three are
covering the Middle East and even
covering
Singapore and also covering the other
countries. So by this network,
alhamdulillah, PTVU is seen on three
satellites in Qatar that is Arabs,
Intraat 20 as well as Asia 7. of that
English.